con nuestra segunda invitada el día
vamos a hablar de la controversia que
hay en colombia por las denuncias sobre
la falta de apoyo al fútbol femenino en
el país pese a que la selección femenina
brilló en esta pasada copa américa
quedando subcampeona perdiendo ante
brasil en el segundo semestre de este
año además no habrá liga profesional
femenina hay denuncias también sobre
vetos a jugadoras que han pedido mejores
condiciones para desempeñar su profesión
pues todo esto está pasando
lamentablemente en la liga profesional
de fútbol femenino aquí en colombia
saludamos entonces a nuestra segunda
invitada el día ya es yoreli rincón
futbolista profesional actual jugadora
de
de la sample sant pere sampol doria y
campeona sampdoria y campeona de la liga
2018 perdón por él y por pronunciar mal
el nombre del equipo mejor lo sabrá
nuestro cronista deportes luís mentes
que también está en nuestra mesa de
trabajo esta mañana de miércoles aquí en
directo américa de france 24 el hilo de
la palabra muchas gracias raúl si un
tema muy controversial y que vamos a
ampliar con yoreli theory bienvenida a
frança en 24 en primer lugar hablar un
poquito como podemos entonces hablar o
analizar este desempeño de la selección
colombiana con esa falta de apoyo que
han denunciado y la falta de una liga
buenas tardes luis bueno buenos dias en
colombia
lo bueno es que el talento jamás ha
puesto en duda realmente colombia desde
hace muchísimos años viene mostrando las
capacidades que que nosotros tenemos y
que hemos adquirido con los años
las jugadoras tienen un talento
impresionante es algo nato
lastimosamente no se puede decir que es
algo que venga de
entrenamientos o que venga por una
formación que hay en colombia porque
lastimosamente no la tenemos
pero cada vez seguimos seguimos subiendo
en hasta que habíamos impuesto nosotras
la selección que más nos hicimos llamar
la superpoderosa hace unos años vendía
peces está superada y pues la nuestra el
botón no sólo la copa américa la
selección sub 17 clasificó también al
mundial la selección sub-20 también
clasificó al mundial y bueno la
selección mayores al mundial ya los
juegos olímpicas eso es la muestra de el
talento tan enorme que hay pero
lastimosamente también una muestra del
tan mal manejo del fútbol colombiana
claro yoreli y además no olvidado en los
estadios o llenos en colombia en esta
copa américa femenina pero digamos para
ustedes avanzar para poder tener más
recursos más apoyo quién debería asumir
la responsabilidad de alguna manera de
esta liga femenina del fútbol un ente
como la de mayores la propia federación
de fútbol quien al final se nutre de
ustedes las jugadoras de las que hacen
pues esto posible
este caliente son ellos de mayor y la
federación realmente yo son los que no
es que debería
es su obligación
en todas las federaciones el wazzen es
por fifa bien el apoyo inclusive es
tanto económico asia súper femenino lo
que pasa es que cuando llega a colombia
ese apoyo no se ve reflejado y cuando
hablamos del apoyo cuál es la exigencia
que hacen las jugadoras sobre todo desde
esos niveles inferiores que como bien
apuntas ya han clasificado a estas copas
del mundo pero cuáles son esas
necesidades que están afrontando las
jugadoras el día de hoy
pero yo muchas veces para a veces
hacerle entender a la gente porque dicen
es que estas peladas joven mucho este es
como un comentario vulgar haz de cuenta
para estar ahí estaba una entrevista han
de estar en el estudio tú tienes un
contrario que no te deben trabajar en
ningún otro lado que te hagan un
contrato pero sólo te dan de comer a ti
a tu familia cuatro meses al año eres
capaz de eso es vivir así y mantener a
tu familia con cuatro meses de salario
mínimo no no un salario al menos exigir
un salario mínimo
por su posible no si es imposible
realmente lo que nosotros pedimos nunca
nos hemos querido comparar y eso vale
vale la pena aclarar lo que jamás hemos
querido comparar el con los hombres
porque eso es lo otros nosotros con
comentarios y un poco vulgar es que el
fútbol femenino jamás va a ser igual el
masculino no nos interesa de hecho el
más bonito el femenino que el masculino
no nos interesa comprarlo
porque gracias a la vía a la gente adiós
pues ellos están muy muy estar el gober
femenino perdonen porque un masculino
pues es el deporte top del mundo
nosotros lo que queremos es es una
dignidad
unos trabajos todo el año un salario de
12 meses unas prestaciones un servicio
de al menos tener esto seguridad social
todo el año no cuatro meses porque es
verdad yo me puedo esguinzado un tobillo
durante estos cuatro meses claro me
descubre el club pero sin la liga que es
de febrero a junio y en julio bajando la
escalera en el 15 un tobillo yo no tengo
ni seguro ni un club que me apoye ni un
saludar yo no tengo absolutamente nada
ya que habrá grietas necesidades yo
realice podríamos entonces hablar de una
asociación de jugadoras existe
actualmente como la hay en masculino y
trabajan en pro de conseguir está de
solventar estas necesidades que
presentan los que forman parte de la
liga en el caso de los hombres
esa es la asociación de la filtro pero
apenas está intentando de emplear el
tema de que las mujeres empiecen a
entrar también en la asociación de
fútbolistas pero es verdad que nosotros
hemos tenido el apoyo de ellos algunas
de las denuncias que hemos llegado a
medio ganar ha sido por la la lucha y la
pelea que la asociación ha ganado por
nosotras cuál es el principal digamos
vale una rueda para no poder pues llegar
y para no poder obtener todo lo que
además ustedes se merecen no sea por el
desempeño que han tenido y también para
un poco entender digamos en nuestra
audiencia internacional habla de un
contrato solamente de cuatro meses que
pasa con el resto del año porque digamos
al final no están contratadas pues es
todo un año no y porque además no va a
haber pues una liga profesional de
fútbol femenino en esta temporada luego
del desempeño que han tenido ustedes o
sea porque tanto rechazo por parte de
estas autoridades del fútbol colombiano
que es lo que realmente está pasando
por qué
cuando tienes que sacar plata del
bolsillo o cuando tienes que dejar de
meterte tanto al bolsillo es espesa y el
fútbol femenino cuando no se les explota
como es porque tampoco se les ve el
interés de querer explotarlo en la forma
adecuada
entonces simplemente lo hacen por
hacerlo entonces es bueno demos la estás
peladas algo como por contentillo no sé
12 meses nos va a costar mucho los ligas
nos cuesta mucho si no les damos nada
nos suman un problema ni al igual madre
ante el temor es algo para que nos
molesten tanto es más o menos es un
contentillo de la liga femenina
imposible una liga de tres meses
no y además a que pena bueno también
unas autoridades como lo está diciendo
pues de alguna manera machistas porque
no entiendo cuál sería pues éste esta
traba para poder a ustedes darle la
dignidad que se merecen como jugadoras
como profesionales y como atletas yoreli
lamentable la situación que pasa
actualmente en el fútbol profesional
femenino en colombia y seguramente
también en muchos países de nuestro
continente de nuestra región louis así
es raúl hay países donde contratan a un
número muy reducido de jugadoras y esto
de verdad que dificulta el desarrollo
pero creo que el impulso que está
tomando el fútbol femenino va a
proyectarla y seguro que en los próximos
meses vamos a hablar de esa liga de
fútbol femenino tanto en colombia como
en diversos países de américa latina
ojalá así sea louis y yoreli pues nada
todo nuestro apoyo está pues siempre va
a ser su ventana para cuando quiera
hablar de deporte femenino un gran
abrazo y gracias por estar con nosotros
esta mañana aquí en directo américa de
france 24
no lo es a ustedes por la invitación y
también bueno extenderle es una
invitación a toda la gente que de verdad
sigan apoyando el fútbol femenino y
actual las niñas y actual las mujeres y
ciertos futbolistas que de verdad día a
día se levantan por este maravilloso
deporte